hello everybody a very good morning to
you it is seven o'clock you are very
welcome to join us on the breakfast show
here on Sky News the government will set
out new plans today to stop migrants who
cross the channel in small boats from
seeking Asylum plans which the Home
Secretary herself says push the
boundaries of international law the new
bill is one of Rishi sunak's five
priorities for his time is PM but
critics say I'm workable we'll be live
this morning on both sides of the
channel and we'll hear from the
conservative former Justice secretary
Sir Robert Buckland and Jack straw the
former Home Secretary who himself fell
foul of the law it's Tuesday the 7th of
March
and the Home Secretary admits the
government is pushing the boundaries of
international law as it unveils plans
today to tackle Small Boat Crossings
refugees who cross from here in France
will be banned from seeking a silent
I'll have the latest from Dunkirk
questions for police this morning about
why it took nearly two days to find five
young people involved in a car accident
in Cardiff that left three of them dead
talks begin between the unions and the
health secretary later this morning as
they try to avert more strikes in the
NHS
China says it must get closer to Russia
as the world becomes more turbulent and
issues a warning to the U.S
a warning that hundreds of community
pharmacies could close this year because
of rising costs
three extraordinary women all at the top
of their field now brought together by a
20th century plastic icon but what is it
the Home Secretary will today set out
new plans to ban anyone who arrives in
the UK in a small boat from claiming
Asylum proponents of the new laws say it
shows the government is getting a grip
on channel Crossings but critics say the
proposals are unworkable and will leave
thousands of migrants in limbo part of a
statement from Sue Ella bravaman
published by the telegraph says we must
stop the boats and that's what our bill
will do no more sticking plasters or
shying away from the difficult decisions
myself and also the Prime Minister have
been working tirelessly to ensure we
have a bill that works we've pushed the
boundaries of international law to solve
this crisis if you come here illegally
it must be that you cannot stay let's
get more on this should we Siobhan is
standing by for us in Dunkirk and shiman
is in Dover for us this morning shiman
do you you first of all when will we
hear more about the detail of this
potential new law
well we are going to hear more detail
today as the Home Secretary will be
outlining some of what this legislation
will look like and how it will likely be
implemented but this is of course a
serious issue that the government is
desperately trying to get a hand on as
we know back in 2018 the then Home
Secretary declared a major incident and
at that time around 300 Small Boat
Crossings had been made but it was a
huge increase which is why a major
incident had been declared however
figures from last year show that around
000 people had made those Crossings via
those small boats which are now illegal
Journeys so that's from 300 to 45
000 in just a number of years so of
course the government is now trying to
get a handle of this I'll handle on this
we've also already heard of plans to
send those who travel via these routes
to Rwanda in the legislation today is
expect to expand on that it will mean
that people that enter here via those
small Boat Crossings will be likely
center around it or another third
country of course this has received
opposition from various Charities that
have called these plans unworkable but
for public opinion polls show that
public opinion is certainly on the
government's side
thank you
so looking at from this side of the
channel I think there are two main
things to focus on one how will the
people who are looking to cross respond
and secondly how will the authorities
here respond and if we take the first
one the initial reactions we've got from
people who are waiting in camps here
waiting to cross is that this isn't
going to make any difference and we have
seen in the past that legislation alone
doesn't always disrupt these Crossings
so for example when the Rwanda plan was
initially announced we saw initial
nervousness from some in the camps but
then the crossings continued and in some
cases Smugglers even use these
announcements to try and speed up the
crossings and say get on the boats now
because the window is closing so there
is some unions worn a risk that we could
actually see an uptick in Crossings in
the next few days in terms of how the
authorities here respond well like
everyone else they're still waiting for
the detail but I think the question is
will this push more of the
responsibility back onto the EU and
you've got to remember it's not just you
UK dealing with huge rises in people
coming across the channel the EU has
also seen a 64 rise in people crossing
its borders illegally in the last year
okay ladies for now thank you both thank
you
well plenty of developments expected on
that story today will bring you all of
them here on Sky News including that
common statement from the Home Secretary
later on uh today and in addition to
that the Prime Minister we are expecting
a news conference from him as well
meantime two police forces in Wales are
facing questions over why it took nearly
two days to find five young people
involved in a car crash after a night
out which left three of them dead
Eve Smith and Darcy Ross both 21 died
along with 24 year old Rafael Jean after
the Volkswagen Tiguan they were
traveling in came off the a48 motorway
in the Welsh capital and crashed into
some trees to other people 20 year olds
real 20 year old Sophie Russon and Shane
Lachlan who's 32 were in the same
vehicle both survived but remain in a
critical condition in hospital all five
were reported missing following a night
out were last seen in an area near to
Cardiff at around two o'clock on
Saturday morning police issued an appeal
on Sunday and officers announced the
crash vehicle was found in the early
hours of Monday morning following a
search involving a police helicopter
however a friend of the three women
claims it was members of the public who
found the vehicle both gwent police and
South Wales police say they have
referred themselves to the independent
office for police conduct over the
handling of the investigation something
they say is in line with normal
procedure
the government is in talks with unions
representing nurses ambulance workers
and other NHS workers today Unison will
be leading negotiations for the unions
and says while bitter pay disputes
aren't over yet there's a potential
route out let's find out more should we
Rachel is standing by for us this
morning hi Rachel good morning what is
that route out well this looks like
there is some wiggle room from the
government on pay both for the last
Financial year and for the next we wait
to see whether or not a deal can
actually be done that satisfies both
sides but of course this is positive
noises coming both from the unions and
from the Department of Health who've
opened up their doors today to six
unions representing
physiotherapists
paramedics nurses and midwives as well
the talks are going to be starting we
understand around 10 30 11 o'clock this
morning and it's all about ending these
ongoing strikes this particularly for
the NHS in England that's what these
discussions are all about and I
mentioned pay for their last Financial
year this is something that's been a
real barrier to negotiations so far we
understand the government isn't prepared
to offer a backdated salary for the
22-23 financial year but there could be
a one-off payment on the cards and
they're also thought to be prepared to
move on next year's Financial offer
previously the government had said they
could only afford a 3.5 pay increase for
NHS members perhaps there's some room to
maneuver there now the unions and the
government have said there won't be
commentating on the talks as they
progress they're expected to last for at
least three four days this week also
important to point out that Junior
doctors are not involved in these talks
and they are still planning to walk out
for 72 hours next week so while these
six unions have decided to pause strike
action for now strike action in the NHS
very much still an ongoing problem okay
thanks very much thank you looking at
the front pages for you this morning
starting with the sun no entry reads the
front page with the sun saying people
arriving in small boats will be banned
from today writing in the paper Rishi
sunak declares enough is enough the mail
reports that the Crackdown will push
human rights laws to the limits quoting
Zola Braverman while the I quotes
formatory cabinet minister who says the
migrants plan may be unworkable and
finally the telegraph's new lockdown
files installment claims that Matt
Hancock discussed blocking funds to MPS
who didn't tow the line on lockdown
and meantime let's look at some of
today's other stories for you this
morning a new survey suggests one in
seven people has skipped meals because
of the rising cost of living consumer
organization which also found that
nearly three quarters of people are
turning on the heating less and a fifth
are eating fewer cooked meals
agenda pay Gap in the UK has widened
because some men are being forced to
leave work completely over Rising child
care costs a report by The accountancy
Firm PWC find that nation's average pay
Gap widened by 2.4 percent to 14.4
percent in 2021 in other words the gap
between what the average man and the
average woman is paid an hour has grown
firm says it will now take more than 50
years to reach gender pay parity in the
UK
the king and queen will celebrate
colchester's recently awarded City
status before having afternoon tea in
the library with people from age UK
Colchester officially became a city in
November of last year having been
awarded the status during the Queen's
Platinum Jubilee celebrations
uh in a world first Scotland has banned
the use of a type of anesthetic in its
hospitals on environmental grounds
studies suggest Des Florine a gas which
keeps people unconscious during surgery
is 2 500 times more damaging for the
environment than carbon dioxide and
later in the program discussing the ban
with Dr Kenneth Barker from Scotland's
national green theaters program that to
come also to come on the program for you
this morning half past the executive
director of strategy at the British Red
Cross Christina Marriott joins us to
discuss the new migration plan
with the situation becoming increasingly
desperate in the fight for back boot in
Ukraine we'll speak to General Lord
dannett former Chief of the general
staff China has warned of conflict and
confrontation if the U.S doesn't change
its path towards it and says they are
being pushed closer to Russia let's get
more should we Helena is standing behind
for us in Beijing this morning hello to
um Ellen on a very good morning to you
so China becoming an increasingly more
important player in what's happening in
Ukraine
yeah that's absolutely right and today
we got a bit of an insight into that
because it was the first press
conference given by a man called
chingong he is the new foreign minister
here in China it's really important to
remember that these press events
um are not really press conferences as
we would understand them in the UK the
questions are pre-selected they are
pre-scripted pre-vetted the answers are
pretty well scripted as well so it's not
really a chance for journalists to
challenge the agenda here but really a
chance for this new foreign minister and
his new job to lay out his mission
statement if you like and we really got
a sense of that there was a very lengthy
section about those tensions with the
United States very much him laying the
blame at the US's door for that and
saying that quote if the US doesn't put
on the brakes no amounts of guard rails
around that relationship would prevent
things from deteriorating further and
then quote conflict would surely follow
so a clear warning there he also used
the language uh describing the internal
situation in America as a new type of
hysterical McCarthyism he called it but
on that war in Ukraine lots of attention
about China's role in that because it
has not taken one side or another but
what it what he did do today was address
accusations from America that China
might be preparing to sell arms to the
Russians he said actually China is one
of the only countries that hasn't
provided arms to anybody and therefore
blame any blame to China is unfair but
crucially he said has not rather than
will not
um and there's going to be a lot of
attention on that in the coming months
now yesterday hundreds of thousands of
you had a look on Twitter with the story
that we thought was worth further debate
and that was whether Boris Johnson's
father should be a knight of the realm
or not today we're really interested to
see if you've got a view on this MPS
have been debating whether people over
60 should be charged for their
prescriptions presently they're free if
you're over 60. currently the government
is planning to align the upper age
exemption for NHS prescription charges
with the state pension age of 66 which
would mean many more people in their 60s
like you at home and perhaps like your
parents would be ineligible what do you
think about over 60s paying for their
prescription medication get in touch and
tell me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
K Burley very interested to hear what
you've got to say on that and we will
share it with the world now returning to
the plans being unveiled today which are
aimed at stopping people from arriving
in the UK
so-called illegally on small boats with
me is the former Justice secretary and
former Lord Chancellor Robert Buckland
hi it's good to see you how is this plan
going to work well as I understand it
the plans which are going to have an
immediate legal effect are designed to
restrict the ability of people who come
here unlawfully to even claim Asylum now
that sounds pretty come unlawfully
though do they they don't come
unlawfully well look my view is that
we've got a lot of people here who've
come through safe routes the Prime
Minister quite rightly said that he
wanted to do more to expand safe routes
of Passage and lawful roots of Passage
that seems to me to be really important
and sensible because by establishing
safe routes it means that people who are
either exploited who are using these
routes to come over the small boats
route clearly aren't taking advantage of
what would be safe and legal roots of
Passage now it's very difficult for the
government I absolutely understand the
quandary there I was having to wrestle
with it when I was in government and
clearly those massive public concern
about the seeming inability of the
authorities to deport people who've
exhausted their rights of appeal here in
this country now if the legislation is
able to fairly deal with that I think it
will deserve support but I think this is
going to be judged by practice and what
happens in the next few months print
that's going to be vital I'm sure but
presently it is not unlawful to travel
across the channel like this it's
unlawful to smuggle people across the
channel like this but these people who
are seeking a better life in the United
Kingdom are not acting unlawfully we've
heard from the Home Secretary today
she's written in the telegraph saying
we've pushed the boundaries of
international law to solve this crisis
well that's going to be challenged time
and again in the courts isn't it well it
does sound like it I mean I've had
assurances that the government isn't
seeking to break international law
that's its obligations under European
convention on human rights the refugee
mention I I welcome that because I I
think a lot of other countries in Europe
and elsewhere struggling with this
problem and I think it would be a bit of
a free-for-all for everybody to try and
uh you know do their own thing in a way
that is not coordinated they have to be
a a prop it has to be a proper process
to allow genuine claimants in which we
get many into our country to make their
claims in a proper way so I'll be
looking very carefully to see in this
new legislation whether there will still
be those exceptions to allow perhaps the
you know the woman from Iran who refuses
to wear the hijab or the refugee coming
from a war-torn part of the world uh who
clearly is is coming for the right
reasons to be able to seek Asylum here
in the UK that's our tradition and I
think it's something that we should uh
support okay even though we do need to
deal with what has become a really
pernicious problem okay five years ago
the then Home Secretary
said there were Rising numbers of small
boats and he was a major incident he was
going to sort it two years ago pretty
Patel promised to stop gangs and to push
boats back if necessary
um
Rishi sunak has previously said we've
heard plans like this before we've heard
plans like this before I know and we've
had a lot of over-promising and under
delivering what I like about the tone
and approach of this prime minister is
that he acknowledges that this is a huge
challenge it's not easy I think what he
wants to do is go one step at a time but
also not just rely on legislation here
in Westminster but to take action more
generally and internationally to see
what can be done to avert the problem
from reaching the channel in the first
place and that's why I think his talks
with the French government are going to
be very important it's clear to me that
they've given them 300 million pounds
since 2014 what have we got to show for
it well I mean this is this is an issue
it does seem to have been thus far that
there's been a reluctance to do
something really deep-seated here I
think mainly because the French think
that there should be a negotiation with
the EU more generally and of course they
have a point that you know refugees or
or people seeking to come to Western
Europe you know it's not about National
borders it's about the fact that Western
Europe is an attractive place to come
economically for many many people and
therefore it seems to me that
International action for example action
that could end for camps in the north
north of France could end the way in
which uh in effect there's a route of
Passage through which allows
exploitation needs to be the order of
the day and the Prime Minister you know
has said that he wants to do more
internationally he announced that deal
with Albania which I thought was a
significant breakthrough okay there's no
poetry in this you know there's no
simple sweeping answer it's going to
take hard grind and individual action
with certain countries which are the
source of the problem but as geopolitics
changes will it not um correct itself
well look I don't have a crystal ball I
think we can say that with the
geopolitics of the sub-Saharan region
the geopolitics of Eastern Europe we are
facing increasing conflict a lack of
resources uh a fight for those resources
Western Europe is seen as a safe haven
uh economically and politically we are
going to be an attractive place for
people to come and we're not subundered
we might say what's wrong with that well
look I've always said that where people
have a genuine reason to want to seek
Asylum then we should welcome them we've
always done so we've done so for
hundreds of years but it is important
that our Fair systems are not abused and
that we're not in effect taken for a
ride by people who are exploiting others
and who are seeking to make a profit out
of criminality we spent a fortune as I
said with the French 300 million we've
given the Rwandan government 200 million
thereabytes half a billion pounds what
have we actually got to show for it well
I I think with Rwanda we're very much in
the early stages
and I think that that the high court has
ruled that the framework is lawful they
were very critical of the individual
cases that were processed clearly the
home office has got to do his homework
and do better in order to process cases
like that but I think Rwanda is actually
a small part of a bigger response that
is needed as I've mentioned I think it's
essential that we do a deal a further
and comprehensive deal with France and
indeed other European countries if we
can and that the Prime Minister uses a
raft of different approaches here in
order to deal with a problem that if
this particular manifestation of small
boats disappears might pop up again in
lorries as we had some years ago I get
that's that there's an increase in in
small boats because you've managed to
plug the Gap when it comes to lorries I
get that but nevertheless 40 odd
thousand people 45 000 people came
across the channel last year something
like 200 even if it does work we'll be
going to Rwanda what are you going to do
with the others
well what do you think about this idea
about a dilapidated cruise ships or old
military camps well I mean military
times in Humane well they have to be
Humane and I'm not against the idea of
using sensible facilities that can work
in a humane way hotels are clearly very
expensive uh option here in fact the
only option that the government has at
the moment and and that's not proving to
be a universal success to say the least
so I I understand that the quantity of
the government is in but unless there is
a more of an international approach to
this and unless there is that attempt to
try and root out to the cause of this
and the routes that I used then I think
that legislation on its own will not
achieve the results that some people
think that it can achieve let me put
this to you finally if I may um so
Robert and that says I'm sure it'll be a
surprise to a lot of our viewers this
morning the biggest number of people who
have stayed illegal legally in the
United Kingdom are those that have
overstayed their visas and they've come
here legally what you're going to do
about them well uh okay it's a very very
good question there's clearly an issue
here as to process and as to the way in
which these particular regimes are
policed I think that we've got to be
honest about migration my view is that
if students are here as long as they're
going back at the end of their courses
and are not out staying their visas
unlawfully I don't really think we
should be counting them as immigrants in
the sense of people wanting to stay here
permanently if you do that you get a
much more realistic sense of what is
going on but you know I've said for a
long time we have a number of people
here who've come come to this country
slipped through the net are probably
working under the radar not paying their
tax we need to address that issue as
well and that's why I think that you
know with all these backlogs of people
waiting for their claims to be processed
why aren't they putting something
productive back into our society perhaps
well okay My Views I think we should
yeah you know I've said after six months
they should be working and then we'll
know where they are and be able to put
them on a cruise ship will we well yeah
look I I I think that there's a lot of
knee-jerk reactions to this problem that
actually don't get near solving it and
what I'm hearing from the prime minister
is a much more grown-up approach to this
an honest assessment that this is tough
but also an acknowledgment and
legislation on its own will not be
enough and that unless we get that
International cooperation this problem
will not be solved for Britain and
indeed for other countries in Western
Europe that are facing equal pressures
Sir Robert it's always great to see you
thank you very much indeed for joining
us thank you
um
this is a thought for people who are
potentially sleeping rough tonight and
we do see a lot of them not only on the
streets of the capital but right around
the country tonight could be the coldest
night of the year so far the Met Office
is warning a yellow weather warning for
snow and ice is in place for parts of
England Scotland Wales and Northern
Ireland with a late winter blast setting
very cold Arctic air sweeping across the
UK should we get more on that Joe's
standing by for us Good Morning Joe
good morning Kay yes the covering of
snow where I am on the grass here and on
the cars but the Pavements are still
clear but some Icy stretches this
morning and let you say there are
warnings in place and last night wasn't
quite as cold as we've seen so far
earlier in the year down to minus eight
degrees Celsius in Scotland but we could
see in the coming nights minus 10 to
minus 15 degrees Celsius so those are
the temperatures at the moment so a very
cold start in the north not quite as
cold in the South it's actually seven
degrees in Newquay and then there are
warnings in place and the warning across
Northern Scotland and across Northeast
England covers
um throughout the day snow showers there
could see a further 10 centimeters in
places the morning across Northern
Ireland and then across parts of Wales
and Central and Southern England those
will expire at 10 A.M this morning but
there are further warnings through the
course of the week so it is worth
keeping an eye on the forecast there'll
be further snow possible in the south on
Wednesday and then that risk transfers
further north where we could see grace
impacts across Northern parts on
Thursday and Friday so it's worth
keeping an eye on the forecast
warm memories wherever you go
to fly to fly the weather sponsored by
Qatar Airways
a Northerly flow bringing very cold air
especially to the north with a risk of
snow ice and as Joe is saying overnight
Frost
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
time now for a look through some of the
photos that have caught our eye today
here we go into the world of the ancient
Egyptians archaeologists have Unearthed
a sphinx-like statue and the remains of
a shrine in an ancient temple in
southern Egypt archaeologists believe
the statues smiling features
May belong to the Roman Emperor Claudius
hi Claudius who extended Rome's that was
a northern joke Rome's rule into North
Africa between 41 and 54 A.D the
archaeologists also found a tablet
dating to ancient Roman times with
demotic and hieroglyphic
inscriptions that's what they are top
stories for you this morning the Home
Secretary admits the government is
pushing the boundaries of international
law with new legislation to tackle small
boats crossing the channel
questions for police in Wales over why
it took nearly two days to find five
young people involved in a car crash in
Cardiff that left three of them dead
talks begin between the unions and the
health secretary later this morning as
they try to avert more strikes in the
NHS
[Music]
the former Justice secretary and Lord
Chancellor Robert Buckland was here
earlier I asked him about the Home
Secretary saying that the government is
pushing the boundaries of international
law to the Limit with the new migration
plans
I've had assurances that the government
isn't seeking to break international law
that's its obligations under European
convention on human rights the refugee
convention I I welcome that because I I
think a lot of other countries in Europe
and elsewhere are struggling with this
problem and I think it would be a bit of
a free-for-all for everybody to try and
uh you know do their own thing in a way
that is not coordinated
so what sort of challenges is the prime
minister and the Home Secretary facing
nobody knows better than our Tamara hi
good morning morning Kay well Rishi
sunak promised at the beginning of this
year to stop the small boats and
speaking to conservative MPS last night
some of them wondering why he didn't say
limit them restrict them reduce it
because stopping small boats sounds like
a huge undertaking which is going to be
very difficult to do now the way the
government are proposing to do this
having as Robert Bucklin acknowledged
over-promised and under delivered on
this in the past is a new legal route
they're going to put in this bill which
we will see the details of today a duty
to remove anyone who comes across the
channel and make sure that that is put
above consideration such as their right
to claim Asylum their rights under
modern slavery laws and their rights
under human rights laws now of course
there will be exemptions for under 18s
for people who are described as having a
serious illness but the government also
wants to do something they haven't tried
before which is to back date it to when
the bill is published to a day so you
don't get a rush of people trying to
come in before this legislation is
passed now it's going to take probably
quite a long time months even longer for
this to get through Parliament and what
effect it will end up having is
difficult to say it's been very
difficult to do this in the past and
everybody who comes over may be able to
appeal to to question the decision the
idea that you could put 45 000 people
across the channel last year into
detention and then remove them all given
what the numbers have been looking like
over the last year seems to many looking
at it to be a very difficult task okay
for now tomorrow thanks very much indeed
well we are going to be talking about
this story throughout the day today it's
something like 45
000 people traveled across the channel
last year in these small boats um it's
important to underline that their
actions are not illegal despite what the
government would have us believe those
that smuggle them very much illegal act
um and their our attempts to try to
track them down in some numbers we'll be
hearing from the Home Secretary in the
House of Commons later on today and then
the Prime Minister will be holding a
news conference
um late afternoon is what we're hearing
well the executive director of strategy
for the British Red Cross that's
Christina Marriott is with us hi good
morning thank you so much for taking the
time to join us on the program
um so the we're hearing from the Home
Secretary that she's going to stretch
international law to the Limit and then
it is going to be illegal to cross the
channel in a small boat
we struggle with how that can be illegal
because under the international
conventions people have the right to
come to a country to claim Asylum and
this is one of the problems with what we
think is proposed in the bill
to claim asylum in the UK you have to
reach the soils of the UK unless you
come from Ukraine or Hong Kong or you're
one of the very lucky 1400 people who
last year we resettled through the
international schemes so people have to
come to the UK in order to be able to
claim Asylum under this bill it's
proposed that once they reach the UK
they will be taken out of the Asylum
system and we think this puts a real
Catch-22 right at the heart of our
Asylum system because we wonder if you
are fleeing persecution if or War if you
are running from Afghanistan or Syria in
fear of your life how are you going to
be able to claim asylum in the UK we've
got us done in Syria very different to
countries like Albania aren't they they
are they are and that's why we have an
asylum system so we know that they have
very different rates of gaining Asylum
when they apply so you do think
albanians should go back home I think if
they don't have a valid Asylum claim
then we are in support of people with
being returned to countries
um but what we need for that is a really
fair and fast Asylum system and that's
what we don't have at the minute so for
example 98 of people from Afghanistan
and Syria who claim Asylum receive it
for very good reasons we know that they
are in fear of their lives we know the
mates for albanians are very different I
don't think we know everything about
albanians at the moment but we do know
their rates through the Asylum system
are very different and we would agree
with returns why don't people
seek asylum in the first safe country
which is not the UK
so
there's no legal requirement for them to
do so under the conventions and one of
the reasons is the conventions are there
to globally spread the load actually
what happens is the vast majority of
people either stay in the country that
they're from they're just internally
displaced or they do stay in the
neighboring country and that's why we
see really high rates of refugees in
countries like turkey and Colombia and
Uganda the vast majority of refugees are
we in Africa Asia South America close to
where they've come from but why then do
people get on a small boat on the coast
of France and make that absolutely
terrifying Crossing in those very small
dinghies Inflatables many of them which
don't make it and have to be rescued or
Worse to the United Kingdom is it
because we're an easy touch
so what the evidence shows the home
office commissioned their own research
and what we hear working with 30 000
refugees and Asylum Seekers every year
it's time and time again we hear that
people actually don't know what the
Asylum system is here and they also
don't know what the welfare system is
here they don't think of us as a soft
touch because they don't know the detail
so how do they come they come for a
variety of reasons we hear from some
people that they actually don't know
where they're being taken to by
Smugglers
Sometimes they come because they have
family here already Sometimes they come
because they speak English English is a
global language and people hope to
rebuild their lives well in Britain
they've got family here they know what
the opportunities are they know what the
welfare system is
we do find a degree of naivety about and
and when we think about the welfare
system for those seeking Asylum it's
less than seven pounds a day it's
actually much less generous than most of
Europe and if we look at things like
Asylum rates Asylum rights they're also
less generous than the EU so in the EU
for example if you are an unaccompanied
child you can request for your parent to
join you so if you're a child on your
own who's reached a country you can
request for your parents to join you in
the UK you can't so actually we're not a
soft touch in terms of our Asylum law so
how do we fix it because you know the
government has to that one would say
some would say um in order to win the
next election they need to be seen to be
doing something about migrants coming
here to the UK to seek Asylum uh what
would you suggest they do so we need to
get really pragmatic here what we can't
do is hope that deterring people will
work because we know they don't know
about the Asylum system and therefore
just hoping that getting tougher and
harsher will work because it won't what
we need to do is speed up things like
our Asylum system so we process our
productivity of the assignment systems
really dropped back in 2014 nine in ten
people got their first decision in the
first six months of their application
last year it was less than one in ten
people got it and that's where the
backlog is what we need is higher
productivity in the home office which
allows people to get through the Asylum
system faster and then if they are if
they are genuine refugees they can be
allowed to work resettle stock
contributing to the UK and if they're
not then we can think about returning
people we don't think this bill will
work because we don't think it will
deter people because they don't know and
we think the government will struggle to
return people to other countries because
they won't have been through an asylum
system and that takes both those people
and the UK taxpayer into a limbo into a
limbo we can't find a way out of because
we're not making a decision final
thought Christina disused cruise ship
sounds like a cushy life to some it
really isn't this year's cruise ships
with an indefinite detention we know is
really damaging to people's mental
health to their physical health we know
people want to work and rebuild lives
and being trapped in a prison whether
it's a floating prison or not is not a
cushy life it's an indefinite limbo
which is very very bad for people and
it's very bad for the UK as well it's
good to see you thanks for joining us on
the program thank you still to come it's
been called the world's greatest living
Explorer and today he's celebrating his
79th birthday who is it finally after
the break
thank you
the Press preview a first look at the
front pages as they arrive there's a
feeling amongst some commentators that
it's not the most respectful timing I
think there's a word for it fake news I
mean it's
delving deeper into the stories with
different perspectives on tomorrow's
headlines we really haven't seen the
government getting around the table and
negotiating why did they do that there
are no easy answers to those questions
the Press preview delivering you
tomorrow's news tonight on Sky News
now before the break we were asking you
which world record-breaking Explorer
turned 79 today do you know
here he is runoff finds he was the first
person to travel by surface to both
poles and the first across Antarctica by
foot among uh more than 30 Expeditions
he also holds the record for the oldest
Britain to successfully climb Mount
Everest which is pretty impressive he's
enjoyed some of the coldest and most
hostile places on the planet losing
several fingertips to frostbite in the
process if you haven't read his account
of losing the tips of his fingers and
how he managed to cut them off then
check out his book he is an amazing
human
meantime Ukraine's top generals and
president zielinski are vowing to fight
on in back route the eastern city
besieged by Russian forces Moscow is
trying to secure its major Battlefield
gain in more than six months speaking in
his nightly address president zielinski
said his advisors had unanimously agreed
to boost Ukraine's defenses there after
reports last week that Ukrainian
Defenders May Retreat well General Lord
done it former Chief of the general
staff is here with me this morning hi my
lord it's good morning thanks for
joining us what's going to happen do you
think well it's interesting of course
it's interesting
um on Sunday when I was talking with
your colleague Sophie on on the morning
program it looked very much as if the
ukrainians were going to withdraw and
they'd actually seemed quite sensible
because buckmood for them had almost
achieved its purpose turning out to be a
killing ground for very large numbers
particularly Wagner group soldiers but
um reports over the last 24 hours or so
indicate that there's growing is quiet
within the Russian ranks tension between
the Wagner Chief and other Russian
generals so I think what zelinski has
now decided on advisory his generals is
actually no we're going to hold on in
backwood because our presence there is
causing dissent and confusion and
disharmony amongst the Russians so it
could be quite a clever move to have
changed what was going to be their
tactical move a lot of people struggle
to find back moot on a on a map why is
it strategically important it's not it
is in central eastern Ukraine it's
become totemic it's become Titanic
largely because
um the Wagner group wanted to show that
they could capture somewhere that the
Russian army couldn't do this goes back
to last Autumn and for the last six
months almost almost incessantly wave
after wave of Russian but particularly
Wagner recruited ex-prison as many of
them have been thrown away in trying to
capture Bachman now from the ukrainian's
point of view they they've managed to
hold on in their defensive positions and
they've killed tens of thousands of of
Russians so so it's become totemic
insofar as
Russia really wanted to have a victory
which they've been denied and the
ukrainians have been perfectly capable
of holding on and it sounds rather
gruesome to say take satisfaction from
the large number of casualties that
they've inflicted on the Russians so
yeah strategically it hasn't got much
significance but tactically it's turned
out to be quite important I was
listening to
um an account of the eastern part of
Ukraine a suggestion that the life
expectancy for some Russian soldiers in
varying Parts was three hours which is
alarming where has this spring offensive
that we were hearing about what's
happened
I don't think we've really seen the
start of the fabled Russian spring
offensive I think at some stage they
have got to use in large numbers not
just the Wagner group but in large
numbers the two three hundred thousand
we understand that they conscripted
towards the end of last year but if one
thinks about it um how much training
will they have had particularly during
this winter the clothing they've been
equipped with is terrible and usually
the winter has been Russia's friend I
think in this case they're hastily
mobilized poorly trained poorly clothes
poorly equipped Army has had to really
suffer during the winter so
um I think we may well see some form of
more concerted attempt by the Russians
to mount an offensive but on the
evidence of everything we've seen it'll
fail it'll be characterized by mass
infantry attacks backed up by artillery
but attacking prepared Ukrainian
positions many young Russian men will
lose their lives which are a tragedy
absolutely absolutely um let's talk
about the commons defense select
committee if we may the committee says
it could take 10 years to rebuild
Britain's supply of ammunition that's
alarming
it is alarming
um of course British industry could do
anything if it was minded to do so but
it I think industrialists have got to
believe that there is Cash behind what
the mod is asking them to do and that
there is a political determination to
say we must get on we must do this we
must replenish our stocks as quickly as
possible and I think we're not hearing
yet strong enough political
determination to increase our defense
budget to make good the stocks that
we've been expending and indeed and I
would say this and I've said it so many
times before actually increased the
priority of spending on defense for our
land forces this land war in Europe over
the last year has been a very rude wake
up that land Warfare is not over main
battle tanks still have a role to play
and we've really got to understand that
commit to it additional money
particularly for our landforces and of
course as I was just suggesting making
up the deficit of our ammunition stocks
that we have given quite properly to
Ukraine and that land Force some of it
is 50 years old well Kate it is
um it's uh I've challenging me in battle
tanks our Warrior I'm an infantry
fighting vehicles are as90
self-propelled guns where all equipments
that came in in the late 1980s at the
height of the Cold War and played a
really significant role this was
Margaret Thatcher's Government after all
she and Ronald Reagan really led the
West in a very concerted fashion at that
time and it was because we were putting
more money into our conventional
Weaponry at the times was one of the
factors that actually LED eventually to
the collapse of the Warsaw Pact and and
the Soviet Union the fact that 50 years
old doesn't matter so much the hardware
doesn't deteriorate the critical thing
is upgrades to the to the software to
the equipment to the anti-drone devices
all the sort of modern of the aspects of
modern warfare needs to be added onto
these armored vehicles
do you think that NATO is as United as
it should be towards
um helping what's happening in Ukraine
by and large today it is the question is
what happens tomorrow I think there is a
danger and of course this is one of
Putin's games that he's been trying to
extend this war in the hope that the
cost of supporting Ukraine will be felt
by some Western countries to be too
great probably hoping that um the United
States presidential election will
produce another government there that
will take a different view so
um I think today NATO is pretty cohesive
what happens tomorrow the day after
tomorrow I think that's the open
question okay uh it's good to talk to
you my Lord thank you very much indeed
for joining us on the program thank you
um quick look at what's happening as far
as the weather's concerned
[Music]
wherever you
ever you go weather sponsored by Qatar
Airways
Northerly flow bringing very cold air
especially to the north with a risk of
snow ice and overnight frosts